is it fair to say that you're a 19 year
old kid who dropped out of college for a
semester because you're anticipating the
bitcoin bull run being absolutely
breathtaking the rest of this year
yeah definitely that that had a lot to
do with my thought process it's like
i think i think you know if we were in a
bear market i may have not made that
decision right but i think like i'm
going to be very busy over the coming
months and so you know for now i think
like just taking a break from school is
probably the the best choice at least in
the me and you know in the midterm but
yeah i think we're gonna have a wild q4
just based off of
um you know when you look at this data
in combination like of you know with
what i kind of hear anecdotally from
some you know some people with many more
connections than myself um it seems like
both of those are kind of aligning to
you know there's some uh
perhaps big buyers that that came in you
know down and over the last couple
months um and you know i think we're
gonna probably see uh some interesting
announcements towards the end of the
year but we'll see what happens and as
that happens through the end of q4 uh
everything that we're seeing on chain
right now the reason why uh you think
that you're a lot of your time's gonna
be focused here is just that you know we
continue to move significantly upwards
because there's so many people holding
on to bitcoin with strong hands and as
that new demand comes in the price has
to accelerate rapidly to kind of
accommodate everyone
yeah exactly and like one chart like we
skipped over but if you look at the
broader trend of a liquid supply um the
liquid supply shock ratio what you see
is that we've been in this kind of like
descending channel for all of bitcoin's
history um and then after covet of last
year we actually broke above that and
we're kind of just free floating uh way
above this this channel so
to me what that's showing is like the
broader huddling behavior is is unlike
dare i say this time is different um
it's unlike anything from any previous
uh bull run that we've been in um so
yeah like you're seeing really strong um
you know
buying and holding from from these new
market participants like also really
strong maturation of coins so like when
you look at like the realized cap hoddle
waves you see the market participants
that came in over the last six months or
the last year they're starting to those
coins are starting to age um which which
is a good sign once again that like
people are coming in buying and holding
um you know it seems like the whole
narrative about you know people just
buying you know bitcoin with the
long-term uh you know
uh thesis on on how it's going to be
maybe you know an inflation hedge or
whatever it may be um i think the data
to an extent does reflect that
got it joe john you guys got any
questions uh i'll go first will you're a
legend uh congrats on on taking uh
making the decision to take a semester
off i think you're making a right
decision uh i think we're gonna see some
uh interesting price action like you
said and you will be very busy with that
said uh
what what worries you like right like a
lot of this data looks great everything
we're hearing sounds great is there
anything that you're watching and you're
just uh you know keeping an eye on for
the bear case and you're and protecting
the downside a little bit
yeah for sure um you know first of all i
would be like are these long-term
holders like kind of what we touched on
are they taking exit liquidity that's
kind of the last real like bear case in
my mind um also you can make an argument
that because uh like transactional
activity is low that that's somewhat of
a bearish thing but i kind of see both
ways because i also think that um
the the fact that there's no you know
the mempool is freed up it's it's kind
of showing that there's no like
speculative mania in the market right
now it's just you know experienced mark
participants um you also see that in in
like i'm laughing because i know i'm
like turning this into a bullish thing
but you also see like um you know a
large portion of volume is from from
larger mark participants so like the
amount of value transacted is mostly
large transactions so yeah i think like
there's a lot of speculation out of the
market but um yeah some people some
people would would see that as a bearish
thing that there's not a lot of you know
monetary value flowing through the
network um and it also doesn't look like
there's like really strong um demand to
to use the network right now when you
look at like the mempool um or like
number of transactions and stuff but
yeah like some people say that you know
that's just a reflection there's no
speculation in the market um you know
you have like transaction batching
that's now um used by coinbase although
i don't know to what extent that that's
the case but yeah
i i think you can make an argument there
that's that that's potentially a bearish
thing what's up guys bang bang thanks so
much for watching the best business show
today if we're going to be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you ten dollars in bitcoin for free it's
that simple head on over to sofi.com to
get started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more of the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]
you